and say yeah you just tell them this is
available yeah in any number okay um any
print in African print designer Sylvia
owari is well aware that the African
look is fashionable these days her new
collection features sports inspired
t-shirts with details in typical African
colors and patterns
it's not necessarily copying it's an
inspiration getting an idea from
somewhere and as saying ok yes we do I
do do so many collections but right now
I felt it was about time to also do
something that is not only here it's
something that I can be able to sell
anywhere in the world one of her
customers is moses cata visiting from
germany where he's lived for 15 years
he's come to pick up some gifts to take
back with him and to make a point
I wish the German is together the real
picture of Africans especially you
London's I think we are trying to make
it the standard of living is becoming up
and it is not all that bad as bad as we
see on the TV there's a growing middle
class in the country and rising numbers
of entrepreneurs the textiles industry
is also changing but most people in
Kampala still buy used clothes from
Europe and Asia at a we know market
Silvia owari gets a lot of ideas here at
the market but she also blames these
imports for the sorry state of the local
textiles industry we have the best in
the world second to Egypt so we are not
using the resources that you basically
have we have 68 percent of the whole
population are you so if we set up
factories we can be able to make enough
clothes that can be able to enough for a
whole basically for the whole country
that would be an opportunity for the
country's many unemployed that includes
people like Anisha Vita after she left
school she spent three years looking for
a job now she's training to be a
seamstress in a new textiles Factory
I love doing that so much cause this my
childhood I love designing so much so
when I had about all of them that
they're doing uploading spinning I loved
it so much that's when I joined them the
company spins yarn from cotton grown in
Uganda and sells almost all of it abroad
but the company is looking to boost
revenue it now produces everything from
thread to clothes and low wages make the
company competitive
he are still there is a 80 to $90 110
dollars for the labor salary and wages
cyanide is reaching approximately
hundred fifty two hundred and seventy
dollars minimum India Bangladesh also he
is having hundred sixty two hundred and
seventy five dollars per worker per
month low wages are one of Uganda's
advantages as a production site and I
hope to attract European and US textiles
companies in future t-shirts for the
German Auto Group will be manufactured
here to 100 thousand euros have been
invested in sewing machines that are now
ready and waiting they were delivered
from Germany six weeks ago this is
basically the requirement what we have
to meet up the export of the European
and the US market t-shirt sequence they
basically it is for the automatic water
printing on the t-shirts when you feel
that print on the t-shirts you will not
feel it at all
designer Sylvia owari has her collection
manufactured in her own workshops she's
trained two hundred women as
seamstresses an order recently came in
from a boutique in Los Angeles for
t-shirts skirts and shorts 200 pieces in
all
but Sylvia doesn't want to say how much
she's going to earn on the order
it's not just necessarily how much or
how big the order is is as being being
out there to be for us to be exposed and
start to be in stores all over the world
that's what's important the global
textiles market is worth nearly 800
billion dollars and local businesses in
Uganda would like to have a share of it